what am i doing now
i'm doing the reuben report i'm dave
rubin it's july 14th 2022 we are live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
subscribe if you have not and of course
as you know because you watched your
show every day
today is a big day here in miami because
i will be at the miami improv tonight
with a live reuben report episode with
all new clips including of that guy joe
biden tonight why am i talking like this
dave rubin.com events and christina
pusha who is ron desantis press
secretary will be joining me for an
interview we're going to do some news
and current events uh with fox news
contributor lisa booth uh and my buddy
dave roboy and we're going to do a live
q a and a whole bunch of other stuff we
got t-shirts maybe some books
mugs what else do we have we can give
these people some other things
lanyards there's all kinds of stuff
where's the lanyard give someone find
that lanyard i want to show the people
the lanyard we've got the vip lanyard
you get the one second hug if you're a
vip we got a lanyard here give me a let
me look at one of these lanyards there
we go look at this thing this is a
beautiful here give me a whole bunch of
lanyards we got a hole they're all
together i got all these lanyards you
get one of these with me and our fancy
reuben report miami logo very exciting
we're going to separate those later
right that's not for one person okay
very good
uh okay so that's tonight and you go to
daverubin.com events there's about 10
tickets left i think okay uh what we're
doing today is uh a reuben report locals
community q a but we are going to start
today uh by talking about this fouchy
guy and a little bit about covert i know
if you're watching the show you've moved
on from kovid if you'd like to take
whatever precautions in your own life to
wear a mask or put a ziploc bag on your
head or whatever you do inject yourself
with chlorine every day that's on you i
know that you've basically moved past it
but these people they just
want to bring it back and get the power
back and make more money and a whole
bunch of other stuff and fauci who as
you know even though he's vaxxed and
boosted out the wazoo and everything
else he got covered a week and a half
ago he's basically admitting that none
of this makes any sense at this point so
we're gonna do a couple clips on that
and then we'll get to the uh community q
a but real quick let me talk to you guys
about ramp do you want a better way to
simplify your business finances across
expenses payments and accounting if so
ramp could be a total game changer ramp
is a corporate card and a financial
software suite designed to help you save
time and put money back in your pocket
the product gives finance terms
unprecedented control and insight with
company spend with ramp you're able to
create budgets issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
and automate expense reporting so you
can stop wasting time at the end of the
month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to the time you'll
save each month on employee expenses
will allow you to close your books in
days not weeks it's easy to use get
started issue virtual and physical cards
and start making payments in less than
15 minutes whether you have five
employees or five thousand and now get
two hundred fifty dollars when you join
ramp just go to ramp.com
reubenramp.com
reuben that's ramp dot com slash reuben
okay so fouchy lord fauci the infallible
fouchy uh he's back
and uh despite the fact that he's
warning us all about covet again and
kind of wants everybody to mask up and
the rest of it uh he's also admitting
that vaccines don't really protect
against getting infected with coved
whoopsie-doo
here's the videotape people heard oh my
gosh this has happened you know to dr
anthony fauci uh everyone knows someone
who's gotten this again and sometimes
again after that and they're beginning
to wonder about the regiment for
treating it uh you know
whether you get two vaccination shots
whether you've got a booster another
booster
they just don't know what do you tell
them
well i that that's a great question and
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to clarify it neil there's no doubt that
the vaccines themselves particularly
vaccine plus a booster at the
appropriate time when you become
eligible for a booster
for more than one booster if you're over
50 years old you get eligibility for two
boosters one of the things that's clear
from the data
that even though vaccines because of the
high degree of transmissibility of this
virus
don't protect overly well as it were
against infection
they protect quite well
against severe disease leading to
hospitalization
and death and i believe that's the
reason
neil why at my age
being vaccinated and boosted even though
it didn't protect me against infection
i feel confident that it made a major
role
in protecting me from progressing to
severe disease
okay man he is nothing other than a
snake oil salesman at this point first
off for him to admit that even though
vaccines don't protect overly well from
infection they were telling you for a
year we were told if you got the vaccine
you were not going to get covet i mean
remember joe biden last june it's just
about a year ago was saying that fauci
was saying it all along cdc was saying
it then of course the evidence starts
pouring out where all these people who
got the shot got boosted and everything
else uh we're still getting coveted and
still transmitting covets so then the
meme changed they had to change the
messaging and the messaging was suddenly
oh it's not a vaccine like the way we've
always known vaccines meaning that you'd
be hey vaccinated from the thing it's
actually just going to stop you from
being hospitalized there is no evidence
of this i have never seen a study on
this please someone find me the study
that shows that if you are vaxxed and
boosted this is the meme this is what
they all say right everybody who gets
coveted when obama gets coveted and
hillary gets coveted and saki gets
coveted and everybody gets covered they
all say the same thing i'm i got covered
and it's mild and i'm just so happy i
got the shot and got boosted because
otherwise i'd be sicker there's no
evidence of it no evidence i had a talk
with jordan peterson last week we were
trying to find the study we could not
find it there is no evidence they just
keep saying it and by the way the way he
even phrases it in there you know he's
admitting it because he says i believe
he says i believe that at my age because
i'm baxter boosted i didn't have to go
to the hospital he doesn't say there's
actually any evidence of it this is just
the meme so they're just he's just sort
of admitting none of this made any sense
none of it made any sense but he's also
admitting the pandemic will never end
everybody wants to put
this pandemic behind us
and feel and hope that it doesn't exist
it does
dude i want to feel and hope that you
never existed that's where i'm at with
you right now you know why because he's
also pushing masks again you see if you
look at the map
where just a couple of months ago it was
a lot of green and some yellow now we're
seeing a fair amount of orange which
means you really should in an indoor
setting
a congregate setting be wearing masks
it's just the appropriate thing to do to
defend to protect yourself
and your family
nonsense complete nonsense of course if
you're immunocompromised of course if
you're a certain age and everyone is up
to personal choice of course of course
of course the idea that he would go on
cnn two and a half years after six feet
away and stop the spread in 15 days and
all that nonsense that he would still be
telling people to wear masks is
absolutely crazy
absolutely crazy uh but he also works
with this lady rachelle wilinski she
runs the cdc uh this is a woman who
should probably be in jail and yeah she
wants everybody to wear masks too which
is very odd because i thought they were
vaccinating everybody i'm so confused
rochelle to you on uh masking on public
transport
yeah thank you for that question so let
me just reiterate that cdc
recommendations have been and continue
to be to mask in our public transport
corridors so in our airports in our um
in our airways um
on our trains that has not changed it
has not wavered it has been reversed in
the in the courts and that is currently
under legal consideration but the cdc
guidance continues to be to mask in
these quarters and i continue to wear
mine
anyway i know you guys are all over this
the only reason i wanted to show this uh
start the show with this today is
there's now a big uh rumor that in la
they're about to start indoor mask
mandates again which you know what l.a
and cali go for it you guys all should
be masked that would be just great um
but i the real reason i want to show is
because as they're pushing this again
they're trying to scare everybody again
and do you think that maybe they're
trying to scare everybody again because
we just got these 9.1 percent inflation
numbers do you think maybe they needed
to kind of the shell game keeps moving
so they got to keep us distracted um i
just really wanted to reiterate the
point though that you do not have to
listen to anthony fauci or cdc
recommendation or anything else they
have no authority over you you can care
perhaps about what they say and i don't
think that they're all corrupt liars and
i think that the nih and the cdc have
obviously done good work in the past and
everyone has to take into account what's
going on with them and their family and
their own medical history and all of
those things but they will try to scare
you and make it sound like you have to
do
all the stuff because they want you to
and you do not
you
do
not and don't forget it that's where
we're at and that's what we have to
remember and i know that when they bring
mask mandates back in certain places
people will gladly mask up again and
triple mask again and they'll try to
scare the hell out of you and this
variant's the scariest variant of all
variants
you do you people all right uh let's get
to the community q a real quick let me
talk about real estate agents i trust
you guys know that buying a selling a
home is one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be a whole bunch
worse if you're not working with the
right agent generally speaking our homes
are our biggest investment that's a ton
of responsibility and you need an agent
who takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
and then follows you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied the agents they work
with have long track records
and are the best agents in their field
they're part of this audience they share
your values and they're almost anywhere
you want to go just go to
realestateagentsidetrust.com today and
provide them with some basic info their
team will contact you to make an
introduction to a preferred agent in
your town then you live happily ever
after most likely in florida all right
let's get to the community q and a quosi
you says what were your favorite
subjects at school also did you ever
have any girls sweet on you at school uh
well my favorite subjects by far social
studies by far was my favorite subject
which i guess
a little of it leaked into me and here i
am yeah i always liked social studies i
always liked history didn't really like
math didn't really like science not my
thing but social studies and english
were really my things i had a great
social studies american civics 11th
grade teacher mr gessner who was
probably the funniest guy i'd ever met
and he just had such a great way of
talking about things and relating it to
current events and it was right when i
was sort of first getting into politics
this was i was in high school in 94 to
98 and he was just a great funny guy i
think he ended up becoming the vice
president of the uh vice vice principal
of the school uh and did i have any
girls sweet on me yeah chicks always dig
me they've always liked me the girls
have always liked me i uh i did you know
i did my thing back then
you know i don't want to brag but uh
here we are you know what are you gonna
do
uh purdue says hey dave someone must be
running things but who jill newsome
harris gay pete lucifer my vote is for
obama yours yeah i mean this is the
question right this is this is really
the question biden is just the old dude
who's out there poorly reading the stuff
and we all know it so really what's
going on like we would like to think
that we know what's going on but i think
the more that the biden thing breaks
down the more it becomes obvious that
he's not in charge so then it's like who
is in charge who is it when he always
says oh they don't want me to respond to
questions or i'm not going to be out
here too long i'm going to get in
trouble like who's he saying he's going
to get in trouble with who who is really
pulling the strings back there
you know a lot of people think it's some
sort of version of the obama machine
that hillary's hillary machine the
clinton thing has kind of been pushed
away and that the obama thing has kind
of
moved in on that
i don't know exactly like i don't know
exactly i certainly don't think it's
kamala and i don't think it's gay pete
and i don't think it's
newsom or any of those people lucifer is
very possible it is very possible that
lucifer is running this thing but
whoever is running it does not like
america that is obvious does not like
the america that you and i love and
that's what our challenge is over the
next couple years we have to survive
this craziness we have to vote in better
people in the midterms and then we got
to get through you know we still have
two and a half years of biden
and if you think it's bad now of course
it can get worse because everything
they've done has
systematically made it worse we we all
know that so can we get through this
thing i honestly believe that they will
get rid of him i think after the
midterms my gut feeling is this my gut
feeling is this and i know nobody wants
to be in the prediction business because
then they clip it they go you got it
wrong you're an idiot but my feeling is
this that assuming there isn't some
crazy thing nuclear war covid7
really nutty whatever crazy voter
manipulation the republicans will crush
it absolutely crush it in the midterms
desantis will demolish
records in florida these all these are
things that should happen and then the
democrats who will be in complete
shambles will be like we got to blame
somebody and by the way biden oh yeah
we've just kind of come around to it
something ain't right with him
cognitively and they'll just get rid of
him there is no point for the
republicans to impeach joe biden there
is no point to call a 25th amendment on
this guy his own people are going to
take him out and they're planning on it
they are absolutely planning on it let's
not forget
joe biden who's in israel right now
taking meetings over there he's mumbling
and stumbling and everything else and by
the way we'll be showing some of those
clips tonight at the miami at the miami
improv um who showed up at the white
house to talk to
flotus the first lady of the united
states gavin newsom
gavin newsom just showed up at the white
house while the president is not there
uh so they are planning it like that's
why he's showing up and wandering around
the white house he didn't just happen to
show up the day that joe's not there the
plan is i mean they're showing it to us
they're it's right in front of our eyes
guys just got to see it uh jeffrey says
since you live in florida and love
basketball will you go on to interview
some orlando magic basketball star
coaches just on basketball well i had uh
jonathan isaac on who is a great great
dude uh who you know he's got uh we
share many things not only our love in
basketball but we both got torn acls so
he's missed like the last two and a half
seasons poor guy but he was drafted
number six or seven a couple years ago
he has awesome skills and i hope he gets
back to full health and can play again
yeah i'd love to talk to um some
basketball players you know i don't
really watch anymore as you know because
i just can't
deal with the politics anymore i'd love
to talk to michael jordan i talked to
magic johnson i'd love to talk to people
who have sort of transcended the sport
um i'd love to talk to charles barkley
you know people that are sort of outside
of basketball but i kind of grew up uh
loving and watching you know just to
talk basketball on the show with a
current basketball guy um
you know
i would rather do it i would rather do
it over drinks or around the court
actually
joe says do you ever think we will see
the client list that was managed by ms
maxwell and he who shall not be named i
think you're talking about jeffrey
epstein um
you know i didn't talk about that thing
much during the show because it just
felt so greasy and gross and and talk
about misinformation like it all just
felt gross what's crazy about it is
that she now is in jail because of
in essence she was finding the young
girls that were then being prostituted
to these political leaders and media
figures and all of this stuff she goes
to jail epstein of course dies in jail
mysteriously the cameras go out all this
stuff it's like where's the list
i get it you're putting the pimp and the
and the henchwoman in jail for doing the
bad stuff but what about the people who
actually had sex with all the kids and
all that stuff i don't know i don't even
it's just i don't want to talk about it
it's gross and i'd rather not get killed
this afternoon i got a show tonight
prisca says uh what are you reading or
watching lately you know we have been
just so
busy around here and there is
construction constantly a noise like i
don't even have a quiet place to like
sit and read anymore and as much as i
love fart it is very hot even in the
late evenings to sit outside and read so
i haven't been reading that much i
really haven't i miss that and usually
where i read is when i'm on planes
that's my main reading time and i just
have you know since the tour's been over
i haven't been traveling that much and
watching i don't really watch tv anymore
i watch seinfeld i'm in the middle of
season seven i think around episode 18
it was the marble ride a couple days ago
that's what i've seen it a thousand
times and i i love it more each time um
i'm not really watching are you guys
watching anything good you guys watching
anything good nothing nothing nothing
nothing connor wants me to watch uh
sunny in philadelphia it's always
sunnier it's sometimes sunny it's always
sunny over there
yeah so i don't know we'll see yeah i
don't know what do you i'd like to watch
um
yellowstone and secession i guess if i'm
gonna start watching things again uh
everyone's telling me yellowstone would
be right up my alley fighting the
government man uh vika says how do you
think those who accuse desantis of book
banning feel about allowing the bible to
be taught in schools as literature right
of course it's like first off desantis
is not banning any books as a matter of
fact gavin newsom who is soulless if i
do one thing in my life i would like
everyone to start calling him soulless
gavin newsom because i don't believe he
has a soul i believe that if you lie
to the extent that he does about
everything constantly if you're it if
your whole existence is taking more for
yourself as you destroy the people
you're supposed to be governing
destroy their lives while you become
become ultra wealthy you lock them in
your house as you dine with lobbyists et
cetera you don't have a soul to some
degree something like that
um
he
well how would i put this uh wait what
was that what was the original question
i was going on a gavin newsom tangent
there
oh so the bible taught
you see what happens i start talking
about newsome and
so
desantis has not banned anything the
reason i brought up gavin newsom is
because gavin newsom uh has banned books
in california because they've taken
certain books out like to kill a
mockingbird because of words that are in
those books um this is the weird thing
that the left does with all these things
they always accuse you of what they're
doing and
do i first off do i think that the bible
should be taught in school which is a
sort of separate question i don't think
the bible should be taught in school as
if you all have to believe this but the
historical importance of the bible and
how religious stories helped create
civilizations actually is important now
of course they would not want that so
they only want you indoctrinated in
their direction but you know this if the
left if it wasn't for double standards
the left would have no standards at all
monique says have you and david thought
about what you'll tell your boys
if they come home one day asking about
changing their gender
uh no you cannot change your gender uh
sorry dude um yeah they can't change
their gender first of all i guess i
would say two two things
first off you can't change your gender
you're born a certain way okay it is
what it is
yeah sorry can't help you out um if i
guess as an adult
they then said to me
uh dad pop
i've decided to live as a chick and
putting on a dress
and uh we're gonna get some lipstick and
make it happen and i'm gonna call myself
ellen or something um i would say to
them i would actually say to them
something that
would be a bit of an offshoot of what
i've heard jordan say jordan peterson on
this topic which is that let's say you
really really as an adult believe that
you are trans you truly in your heart
you have
[Music]
unfurled all the issues around all of it
and you truly in your heart and again
we're talking about like point zero zero
zero zero zero one percent of children
um
or even adults if you truly believe that
well then what you have to really think
about is okay so if i now spend all of
this money if i go through all of these
changes i take all of these medications
i do these physical changes to my body
will i be happier
after
will i ever look exactly how i want to
look will i ever be able to find a par a
partner who is the type of person i want
to be with like it's not just oh
flip a switch now i'm a chick and
and then there we go so there's sort of
like a
there's a real version of it a reality
version of it which is that you actually
can't change your gender but then
there's another part which is that i
hope that i will raise children that
will
you know
have some level of autonomy over their
lives and really want to think things
through and not make rash decisions and
all of that stuff and that's why what
they're doing to kids now is so perverse
right what they're doing to kids where
it's like you're telling eight-year-olds
that they should be on puberty blockers
and you hide this information from
parents the level of which their brains
are not developed and the level of
destruction you're doing to their
cognitive ability to think properly when
they're just on their way to thinking
properly it's really really twisted so i
would hope that i would be able to to
say to them look the reality is you
can't change your gender but if as an
adult you wish to do something well i
don't own you i can just guide you the
best that i can
and you have to think about all of the
stuff on the other side
something like that
brett says as a fellow future first time
dad i was wondering what type of kids
books and entertainment you'll be
sharing with your kids well
congratulations brett uh you know it's
funny i do this show every day and you
guys hear me talk about politics all the
time but baby one is is due basically in
a month and you know obviously i go off
the grid august 1st
but i've been very aware of that this
time of my life really is coming to a
close right now i went with the team we
went to the marlins game the other night
and i turned to the guys around the
third inning and i was like whoa i just
realized this is the last time
i'm going to a baseball game probably
without a kid certainly not as a father
but probably without a kid for the next
you know many many years
then i pat phoenix on the head and i
said go get yourself a hot dog
uh
so
so what kind of entertainment and books
look prageru is doing a great job with
their kids stuff they they really really
are so prager you kids brett if you're
if you're looking for something to show
your kids to um they've got a bunch of
videos they're i think they're sending
they're put publishing some books as
well uh daily wires putting 100 million
into kids programming i'm not hopefully
going to show them all the stuff that
everyone else is showing them look we
canceled our disney plus account david
and i've already discussed it it's like
what do you do about that like it's it's
easy for me as an adult to be like i'm
canceling disney plus and i'm not
watching obi-wan right like i did it
okay fine so be it um that's one thing
but like when you have kids now it's
like disney wasn't always evil so
on disney plus they have cinderella that
was pretty good remember cinderella she
was pretty good and they've got you know
some of the old stuff uh little mermaid
i like little mermaid uh give me one
more what is what's one you like
101 dial mate here what do you like
you don't watch disney's too cool for
disney what do you like
what
no i'm talking about old school old
school anyway the point is there was
great stuff right for many many years
but then the company shifted into this
propaganda outlet and maybe it was a
propaganda outlet before we even knew it
uh but as we have kids that grow up it's
like okay now they're five six years old
they want to watch those movies am i
gonna stop them from watching disney
movies
probably not but this is i guess this is
the challenge that many of you who are
parents right now are going okay when
can i show my kid a violent movie or a
movie with some sexual content or
support you know everybody in class is
all wearing the shirt from that movie
and my kid just can't see it because i
don't like the diversity equity and
inclusion department at the corporate
office
these are the challenges that i guess i
will have to face
brian says thomas jefferson is my
favorite founding father who's your
favorite if you've heard me say it on
the show i suspect you have not it is
also thomas jefferson i know you could
you could do a million versions of this
uh but thomas jefferson for me
because i've been to monticello which
was his home in virginia i've been many
times and so i've i feel like this sort
of
extra affinity because i've seen where
he lived where they talk about all of
the stuff yes related to slaves and all
of that but that this guy was an
incredible thinker and inventor who was
writing laws to free slaves as he was
having a relationship with the slave
it's such it's such like the
like the gestalt the the complexity of
being a human um and you know they like
all of these awesome things that he did
they have this have you guys been to
monticello any of you guys been there
it's really incredible so it's it's his
awesome estate it's on probably it must
be on like 100 acres or something in
virginia and uh they have he built this
incredible uh you know obviously back
then they didn't have refrigerators
you're not gonna believe it and they
they that he dug this huge thing so he
could keep ice in there so he could have
ice in the middle of the summer in
virginia where it's hot as hell and like
they show you his writing room and his
bedroom and all of this stuff so i feel
like because i've seen some of that it
makes me a little more of a thomas
jefferson guy but if you want more on
some of the founders you know we did a
president's week a couple years ago
where i interviewed some people on i
think we did james madison we did thomas
jefferson we did although he wasn't a
founder we did abraham lincoln and a
couple other presidents that you might
find interesting uh elizabeth says hello
from seattle jeez
good luck with that uh what is your
prediction for exactly how the democrat
party will get rid of kamala and do you
think she'll go quietly well that's a
good question and i was thinking about
it yesterday because gavin shows up as i
said to the white house while biden's
out of town
and it's like he's meeting with kamala
he's meeting with dr jill biden he's
meeting with the white house uh chief of
staff ronald clayne like something is
going on there so they clearly it's just
so obvious it's like it's not like
they're talking about policy in
california related to the federal
government they're talking about the
thing that we all know that we're not
allowed to talk about that this guy's on
his way out and jill's talking about it
with them i mean there is a special
place in hell for that woman so they're
talking about all of that stuff so the
question is well what do you do if the
idea is okay biden's going to step down
then the natural secession obviously is
that the vp moves up so now kamala moves
up so is the negotiation right now okay
who is kamala going to choose
as her
vp
uh i'm i'm actually not totally sure is
the technical version of it if it
immediately happens like if biden or the
president was to just die does the
speaker of the house immediately become
the vp right in that moment
yeah is that right okay so technically
what would happen if we're fully right
on the on the mechanics of all of this
that's the way i've always known it to
be is that kamala would become president
and then nancy pelosi would become vp
but i'm pretty sure then they would have
a process where they could replace nancy
pelosi very quickly and kamala could in
essence choose her own vp perhaps then
you choose newsome
and then i think maybe kamala would see
the writing on the wall and i think she
probably realizes she's in over her head
anyway you just hand it to newsome for
2024 which oh god god it's so evil but
maybe the fight we need to have in
america is just a straight up hey what
do you want america you want cali and
newsom or you want florida and freedom
and desantis and let's just have it out
that might be the best thing we could do
actually
brie
says can you do a series about where you
talk about movies tv shows and books i
think it would be really interesting for
you to do a reaction series for the west
wing because the characters are
democrats who would be walking away from
the left or conservatives that's super
interesting and you know i've never seen
the west wing believe it or not just you
know one of those shows that it's
culturally relevant but it just kind of
gets by yeah
so i never saw it um i that's that
actually is a great idea let's maybe
pick up something around that in the
fall you know we've done a couple uh
movie nights with the locals community
i've been thinking about doing some sort
of book club type thing uh it's just a
matter of managing time and everything
else obviously i had to get through
uh you know this year was so devoted to
getting the book out there and the book
tour and everything else uh now the kids
are coming um but you know we want to
expand on a couple things and by the way
with that in mind we'll make a couple
announcements when i get back on the
grid in september
but i will definitely keep that in mind
it's an interesting idea um byron says
if the presidential race is desantis
versus newsom in 2024 who do you think
would be viable gop and democrat vice
president nominees well i'll tell you
kim reynolds from iowa
i saw her at an event a couple weeks ago
i was super impressed by her have we
reached out to her i think we were going
to reach out to the team all right we're
going to try to get her on the show i
was incredibly impressed by her not only
her knowledge
the way she was talking about fighting
the machine during covid and all that
but she's funny she's kind of got a cute
folksy thing going really really liked
her
and of course you know iowa getting iowa
for the straw poll and everything it
just sort of sets you up well but you're
talking about the vp situation i think
she'd fit in really nicely uh with
desantis i think she'd fit in really
nicely with trump i mean we'll see what
happens there but assuming desantis i
think kim reynolds would be great uh
obviously i think tim scott
from south carolina would be great and
it you know it helps you on the on the
nonsense racial stuff that most people
most conservatives or republicans don't
care about but the media the media would
struggle they'd struggle with that
because he's a black man and you got to
be nice to a black guy but he's also a
republican you got to be mean to a
republican we know which one they choose
they would choose mean um i think he
would be a good choice um i think
there's like i actually think there's a
pretty decent set of options i mean i
don't know that a guy like desantis
needs a guy like say cruz
or
uh rand paul on the more libertarian
side because i don't know that that
brings in a new set of people but then
you've got sort of uh you go with the
nikki haley you could go with the
candace owens you could go with all
sorts of people so i think there's some
interest there on the democrat side i
mean man so let's say it's newsome okay
well now
if kamala's just been pushed out
altogether you have to go black woman
right it's just it's the way these
people think so who's the craziest black
woman we joy read
newsome read 2024
democrats we're taking you to hell
snow says how have your feelings towards
fatherhood changed since you've begun
this journey how did you feel when you
first saw the ultrasounds um
well i'll tell you this this is sort of
interesting i've been having a lot of
dreams about my grandma mimi my grandma
mimi who passed away about 15 years ago
was my dad's mom and she was really the
matriarch of my family and her whole
life was about family if you if you've
just
searched grandma in the dictionary you
should have my grandma mimi's picture
and
i almost every night i'm waking up in
the middle of the night and i'm like i
can't fully put the dream together but
i'm like oh wow i had another dream
about grandma mimi so i've obviously
in my mind just been really thinking
about family and she brings back all of
that that family stuff to me um
i mean i've really been thinking about a
lot of the stuff that if you watch my
interview with jordan we talked about
like you know most people i'm 46 years
old uh most people that have kids you
know usually have kids in their 20s and
30s so i am going to be an older an
older dad and i think there's some
negatives to that and that you know
20 years from now i want to be able to
play catch with this kid but i think
there's benefits to that in that
i've managed over the course of
especially these last couple years to
really get my life in order we have a
solid uh foundation here and a good
marriage and we're you know relatively
financially secure and this kid's gonna
have all kinds of great opportunities
these kids and that hopefully you know
i'm somebody that
these kids will be able to look to for
advice and decency and some level of
truth and all that and i've really been
uh i've been thinking about it a lot and
i've been trying to trying to
sharpen the the corners on places maybe
that that i needed to with that in mind
uh i got i got a couple weeks left uh
patrick i think this is the last
question patrick and then we got a cold
clothes for you says with all the work
going on around your new florida
homestead has your home gym been
finished the gym was supposed to be
finished today
but now i'm told that a part is not
available all that had to happen in the
gym the floors are in the mirrors are in
we got the ac fixed
we got all the stuff
uh we're hanging a tv to get it off the
floor so we have more room on the floor
and in joe biden's economy i don't know
if you know this the supply chain blows
and the piece that was gonna hang the tv
on the ceiling which was supposed to be
here a week ago has been delayed again
so i've got eric downstairs right now
eric's the guy that hangs my stuff
eric has nothing to hang with so i don't
know what eric's doing right now i'm
probably paying him good for you eric
you might be watching this show right
now because you've got nothing to do
thanks to joe biden that's where we're
at anyway hopefully it'll be done in a
couple days uh real quick guys reminder
tonight miami couple tickets left dave
rubin.com events with pusha booth and
reboy uh uh part two of my interview
with patrick bett david from
valuetainment the guy is just an
absolute all-star of clarity economics
freedom all of that stuff that's up on
youtube and rumble the full things up ad
free on locals uh and finally
we leave you with this
uh that joe biden guy who i've been
talking a lot about with well
he's not very good at what he's doing
see you tomorrow ask the right questions
what a stupid song
come on man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program if you take a test where
you're taking cocaine or not what do you
think huh
are you a job what do you say
go back and read what i said
that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
than you do i suspect that's not true
you're saying things you do not know
what you're talking about no one said
that who said that what he said
i have no responses
you don't understand that you're in your
own business
on israel before you drive no you can't
i'm not unless you get in front of the
car as i step on it
okay a number of noxious questions don't
screw around with me let's get it to
give you the right brush no let me
listen to me i'm listening
don't poke that in my face okay buddy